1998 the year of that one godzilla movie
with the puff daddy song
half-life and also the year a new player
in the gaming industry began
to take form
it all began with seamus blackley after
producing the colossal failure jurassic
park trespasser
jamis left video games behind and became
a program manager at microsoft that is
until word got a round of sony's
playstation 2 a video game console said
to rival the graphics of computer games
and a trojan horse for movie
entertainment in living rooms to
microsoft's ceo bill gates
that was a direct threat at first bill
gates turned into the likes of
sega to join forces and even approached
sony's then
ceo nobuyuki ide about a partnership
but to no avail and then seamus blackley
was stricken with inspiration
microsoft should go toe to toe with sony
and make its own video game console
sheamus pitched it to kevin backus
project manager at directx then turned
to ad freeze the dude in charge of the
games division at microsoft
next up the head honcho himself bill
gates they pitched a device that was
powered by windows technology but with
one sole focus to play games and like
that
bill gates gave them his blessing
by 1999 microsoft's console was well
underway
but what's a video game console without
games in 2000
xbox acquired the once apple focused
game studio bungie
for 30 million dollars and tasked them
to pivot away from its open world third
person action game
into a first person shooter for its
upcoming console
a genre that hadn't been truly mastered
on consoles nor
championed since goldeneye for the n64
it was an acquisition that would help
define the console's legacy
and if you're interested in learning
more about that you can watch an entire
episode of our show remember when
all about when halo was originally going
to be a mac
game link in the description below
the development of the xbox was first
publicly revealed to the world
at the game developers conference in
2000 by bill gates
revealing a giant shiny metallic x along
with its tagline
the future of console gaming but it
wouldn't be until early 2001 where we'd
get our first look
at the actual console design at the
consumer electronics show
with the help of dwayne the rock johnson
so if you really want to smell what the
rock is cooking
to to a degree you've never thought you
would before
you're going to get the xbox the xbox
launched on november 15th for 299
it was the first video game console to
stand shoulder to
shoulder with computer tech using a gpu
powered by nvidia
and an internal pc hard drive which was
the first for a console and added to its
iconic tank-like girth speaking of girth
it launched with this colossus
controller
now nicknamed the duke it was nearly
three times the size of ps2's dualshock
2 just
for context the xbox included direct
online access and
could play dvds well sort of
it only worked as long as you had the
dvd movie playback kit which was
an extra 20 bucks the xbox sold a
million units in three weeks
a huge success for a first time console
some notable games it launched with was
odd world munch's odyssey dead or alive
3
project gotham and of course the game
that helped establish an iconic
long-running franchise for the xbox halo
combat evolved
halo combat evolved was a massive
critical success
changing the perception of first-person
shooters on consoles setting a new
president for the genre
and introducing it to an entirely new
audience of gamers by cultivating a new
culture around lan parties that took
basements and college dorm rooms by
storm very quickly
halo became synonymous with the xbox
making master chief's helmet
the face of the brand in 2002 xbox live
was launched it was the service that
changed online gaming forever
and a business model its competitors
would later adapt forget that let's play
the service came bundled with a headset
a requirement that single-handedly
influenced a generation of online gaming
culture with a uh
a very colorful vocabulary
poo come on little boy later that year
xbox launched in japan and with it
introduced the world to the controller s
a smaller less
ergonomically insulting controller than
the duke it continued to sell well in
north america but in japan
barely scraped by with 850 000 units by
the end of that year
additionally the xbox was very expensive
to produce and lost money
with every unit sold but in a drastic
and daring move
microsoft decided to make the console
100 dollars cheaper
putting it at 199 the same price
as the ps2 in hopes to make up for lost
ground against
sony's astronomically successful
playstation 2 which
had sold 50 million units worldwide by
the end of 2002
still while xbox struggled to keep up
killer apps like tom clancy's splinter
cell help boost sales
in the end of that year in 2003 just two
years after the xbox's release microsoft
had already begun planning on the next
console
codenamed xenon while the next
generation xbox was being developed in
the background
at 2004's e3 peter moore famously
revealed the launch date of halo 2 by
getting it tattooed
on his arm halo 2 sold 2.4 million units
in its first
24 hours it made a 125 million in sales
making it the most successful of any
entertainment product in history
at the time and the highest selling og
xbox game
of all time it also came out just in
time for xbox live to go global further
catapulting the service to success
2004 was also the launch of xbox live
arcade a digital video game storefront
paving the way for downloading
additional content for games including
halo 2.
in may 2005 the xbox 360 was unveiled on
mtv with elijah wood and performances by
bands like the killers
xbox 360 launched for 399.
it had an interchangeable external hard
drive it had faceplate customization
and a wireless controller that would set
the standard for all
xbox controllers to follow this time
around microsoft
opted for a sleeker white and gray look
in comparison to the
black cinder block of its predecessor it
was also the first console to implement
gamer tags and one of its most
influential features
the achievement system achievements set
a president for even the likes of valve
which added its own
achievement system to steam in 2007 and
then sony followed suit with trophies
for the playstation 3.
xbox live arcade also made a huge splash
on the xbox 360 opening the gates to a
wider market of games
most notably indie games 2006 brought us
xbox's other defining flagship franchise
gears of war it won many awards
including
game spots game of the year it sold 1
million units in its first two weeks
making it the fastest selling xbox 360
game at the time
and then at e3 that same year peter
moore did the thing he does again
revealing another tattoo release date
for grand theft auto
4. all was going so well for microsoft's
second console
until nine months after its launch
some faulty xbox 360s are literally
melting down while running certain games
a big holiday headache from microsoft
but nintendo and sony appear to be
grinning like else
by august 2006 there was an influx of
consoles being returned
after they'd abruptly stopped working
following the flashing of three red
lights around its power button
earning notoriety as the red ring
of death the cause at first was
difficult to narrow down and pinpoint
head of xbox at the time robbie buck
concluded it was the fault of the
console's engineering claiming that
microsoft took a design first approach
and as a result compromised what was
under the hood
the fiasco resulted in a costly disaster
microsoft set aside 1 billion dollars to
extend
the red ring of death warranty coverage
to three years
meanwhile there was a war on disk
formats hd
dvd versus blu-ray the playstation 3
utilized blu-ray technology which
sony co owned making the ps3 double as a
blu-ray player
an identical strategy sony used for the
ps2
doubling as a dvd player microsoft on
the other hand went the hd dvd room
they released an external hd dvd player
for it
priced at a hundred and ninety dollars
but by 2008 toshiba which was the
principal supporter for the hd dvd
format announced a discontinued hd dvd
support
in 2008. days later microsoft
discontinued its own player 2007
introduced the sleeker slightly more
compact xbox elite
and halo 3. this was the year 343
industries
the halo only studio was formed and
also the departure of halo's original
developer
bungie though bungie continued to
develop halo odst
and halo reach 2008 brought us one of
the most unsuspecting titles to cause a
ripple
through the industry a little game to
come out on the xbox live arcade
called braid it is among the top 10
highest rated xbox 360 games according
to metacritic
and it was the second best-selling xbox
live arcade title that year
right next to castle crashers braid was
among the first
indie games to shift the industry's
perception of independently made games
paving the way for games to follow such
as limbo super meat boy
and fez 2009 was the first public
mention that microsoft was working on
the motion
and voice controlled device the connect
a project that had started
several years prior in 2005. the
nintendo wii sent a shockwave through
the gaming industry with its
revolutionary controller released
back in 2006 tapping into new gaming
demographics from children to
grandparents
though a few years late microsoft was
ready to unveil its own motion control
device
the kinect's intent was to eliminate the
controller altogether
competing head-on with the wii and the
reveal of the kinect brought this
wonderful moment along with it you ever
wonder what the bottom of an avatar shoe
looks like
well bam there it is connect was
released in 2010 alongside the xbox 360
s after only 60 days the kinect had sold
8
million units and by 2011 rumors
circulated microsoft was well underway
on its next console
despite the enormous misstep of the red
ring at death the xbox 360
sold exceptionally well and was
immensely influential thanks to its
achievement implementation
xbox live arcade and its success in
popularizing
indie games and enabling their console
distribution
xbox 360 sold over 80 million units by
the end of the generation nearly four
times more
than its predecessor and just hairs less
than sony's playstation 3.
despite both having lost the sales race
to nintendo's wii
microsoft was officially cemented in the
console market as a major force to be
reckoned with
but that also meant a lot of pressure
for what
was next
following the release of the last and
final iteration of the xbox 360
the e-model microsoft revealed the xbox
one in may
2013 and uh people were
less than thrilled with what was
presented that day
the xbox one didn't seem too focused on
gaming but rather
serving as an all-in-one entertainment
hub even when xbox announced the game
quantum break it had a
tv-like thing integrated into it it was
also the announcement of the halo tv
show where
ever that is today though really it's
definitely actually
absolutely in development on top of all
of that the console was pitched having
loads of barriers and restrictions like
having to be always online no backwards
compatibility
a restriction on used games and connect
was required
with the console heightening people's
concerns of privacy with
an always-on camera microphone device
front and center in their home
oh and aaron paul kept turning people's
xboxes on thanks to this ad
xbox on yo all of which
was packaged for 499
very quickly the console was shrouded in
controversy
it wasn't long before xbox reversed most
of its malign policies
at launch the system did not require you
to be always online and
could play used games but the damage had
been done
and the console's perception had been
tarnished
slowly the tide began to shift in 2014
when phil spencer
former head of microsoft game studios
was made the head of xbox
six months after the xbox one's released
a version of the console was launched
without
the kinect making it 100 cheaper putting
it on par with the playstation 4.
at e3 2015 phil spencer announced
backwards compatibility for xbox one and
the crowd
exploded with applause today
i'm pleased to announce xbox one
backward compatibility
that same year xbox launched its premium
top of the line
highly customizable elite controller
2016 saw the introduction of the xbox
one s
priced between 299 and 399 depending on
the storage size
and interestingly featured a uhd blu-ray
player
something that the ps4 pro did not have
despite
the technology being developed by sony
also that year
microsoft acquired mixer placing its
first steps into the streaming sphere
now the most important year in the xbox
one's lifespan is
undoubtedly 2017. the year xbox truly
began to shift its perception in the
public eye
and lay the foundation for its future
values
and it all started with the announcement
of game pass
a monthly subscription service making a
library of about 100 games available for
9.99 a month
next up the kinect was discontinued
later that year it launched the xbox one
x costing 499
it outputs 4k resolution with
performance improvements
and was the most powerful console on the
market at the time
then at e3 2018 microsoft announced
several acquisitions including
forza developer playground games
hellblade senwa's sacrifice studio ninja
theory
state of decay's undead labs we happy
few devs compulsion games
and outer worlds obsidian entertainment
microsoft also announced the formation
of an entirely new studio
the initiative xbox's quadruple a studio
comprised of industry veterans from
naughty dog bungie and crystal dynamics
microsoft also expanded its market with
the xbox adaptive controller
opening the doors to a group of people
underserved by the gaming industry
xbox kept the momentum high heading into
2019 with one of its biggest years to
date which saw the launch
of the xbox one s all digital edition it
featured no disk drive and was priced at
only 249 meanwhile xbox continued to
support
game pass expanding the service to pc
and launching game pass ultimate which
combined the console and pc service as
well as
xbox live gold the elite series 2
controller also graced the palms of many
gamers
e3 that same year could be xbox's best
to date where keanu reeves took the
stage to reveal
his role in cyberpunk 2077. it's your
breathtaking
it also featured a staggering amount of
game reveals
lastly the indie sweetheart of the
industry and developer of psychonauts 2
double fine join the xbox first party
family
oh and uh mixer microsoft's game
streamer service
makes a deal with one of the world's
most popular streamers
ninja as of today i will be streaming
exclusively
on mixer and if 2019 didn't have enough
xbox excitement
its next generation console the xbox
series x was revealed at the game awards
which brings us to 2020 another exciting
and historical year
for xbox microsoft revealed two models
for the xbox series consoles the
x and the s both of which feature quick
resume allowing the user to have
multiple games running in the background
at once
backwards compatibility with its three
prior generation of games
the smart delivery initiative that
enables folks who bought current gen
versions of games
to get free next-gen upgrades and the
speed of solid-state drives
between microsoft's momentous effort and
focus on backwards compatibility
smart delivery and offering improvements
to past games microsoft is blurring the
lines between console transitions and
redefining how we view
console generations 2020 also saw the
launch of xbox's beta cloud gaming
platform
and just months before the launch of its
new consoles microsoft acquired bethesda
officially expanding its first party
family to a
whopping 23 studios and making it the
owner of franchises such as elder
scrolls
fallout doom wolfenstein dishonored and
many many more that isn't to say xbox
didn't have any losses in 2020.
microsoft officially shut down its gamer
streamer service
mixer a hard blow for many streamers who
had established a brand and audience on
the platform
and halo infinite an initial launch
title and system seller for the xbox
series consoles
was delayed into 2021
and that is it we are all caught up on
21 years of history
with the xbox with xbox on the cusp of
its fourth generation it's suffice to
say that the story
is far from over to stay up to date with
everything the past present and future
of xbox
keep it here at gamespot
[Music]
you